die Mondlandung war ein absoluter
Meilenstein in der Geschichte der
Menschheit eine technische
Meisterleistung ein
jahrhundertevent aber Moment mal wieso
WT die US-Flagge hier so toll im Wind
obwohl es auf dem Mond gar keine Luft
gibt warum sind die Schatten der beiden
Astronauten unterschiedlich lang und
warum sieht man hier keinen einzigen
Stern am Himmel habt ihr euch je gefragt
ob die Bilder der Mondlandung vielleicht
gefaked sind obwohl ca 650 Millionen
Mens auf der ganzen Welt die Mondlandung
live im Fernsehen verfolgt haben gibt es
bis heute viele Zweifel ob das hier
wirklich passiert
[Applaus]
ist mit diesem Satz wird Neil Armstrong
also nicht nur weltberühmt er steht
damit auch im Zentrum der Mutter aller
verschwörungserzählung unter anderem
weil mittlerweile seit über 50 Jahren
kein Mensch mehr einen Fuß auf den Mond
gesetzt hat gibt es bis heute zweifel
ich meine wir haben in der Zwischenzeit
das Internet erfunden künstliche
Intelligenz entwickelt und
Heilungsmethoden für Krebs entdeckt nur
auf den Mond haben wir seit einer halben
Ewigkeit nicht mehr geschafft wenn es
also heute schon so schwer ist auf den
Mond zu gelangen wie soll das dann in
den 60er Jahren geklappt haben was an
den Mythen rund um die Mondlandung dran
ist und vor allem warum sie sich bis
heute so hartnäckig halten das schauen
wir uns jetzt an willkommen beim ZDF
heute background
Check
eine Frage die ich mir bei
verschwörungserzählung häufig Stelle ist
die nach dem warum also warum sollten
die Amerikaner die Mondlandung überhaupt
gefakt haben um das zu verstehen müssen
wir uns zurückbieen in die 1960er Jahre
in die Zeit des Kalten Krieges zwischen
den beiden Weltmächten USA und
Sowjetunion damals teilen die beiden
Supermächte die Welt quasi unter sich
auf die USA dominieren den Westen die
Sowjetunion den Osten es geht um Macht
auf allen Ebenen Politik Wirtschaft
Kultur und Technik aber schnell kämpfen
die beiden Supermächte nicht mehr nur um
die weltliche Vormachtstellung sie
streben ins Weltall 1961 versetzt die
Sowjetunion den Amerikanern einen
empfindlichen Schlag Juri Gagarin
gelingt die Sensation er ist der erste
Mensch im All 8 Jahre später schlagen
die USA mit der Mondlandung zurück es
ist ein wissenschaftlicher und
technologischer Meilenstein und ein
politischer Sieg für die USA den
Präsident John F Kennedy schon Anfang
des jahrzehns als großes Ziel formuliert
hat den ersten Mensch auf den Mond zu
schicken war also das Ziel überhaupt um
sich gegenüber der Sowjetunion zu
beweisen und dafür haben die Amerikaner
wirklich alles getan mit teilweise
verheerenden Folgen das apolloprogramm
hat Neil Armstrong und seine Kollegen
1969 auf den Mond gebracht bis heute ist
es eins der größten und teuersten
Raumfahrtprojekte überhaupt mit einer
unglaublichen Manpower über 400 000
Menschen waren an der Mondlandung
beteiligt
25,8 Milliarden US-Dollar wurden in das
Programm investiert für damalige
Verhältnisse eine astronomisch hohe
Summe das apolloprogramm Bestand
insgesamt aus mehreren Missionen nicht
alle davon hatten das Ziel auf dem Mond
zu landen und auch nicht alle liefen
problemlos ab im Gegenteil schon die
erste Mission Apollo 1 im Januar 1967
endete tragisch bei Tests auf der
Startrampe brach ein Feuer in der Kapsel
aus das verbreitete sich so schnell dass
die drei Piloten Virgil Grissom Edward
white und Roger cherffy keine Chance
hatten innerhalb von Sekunden kamen sie
ums Leben aber zwei Jahre später
gelangen den USA dann das unglaubliche
mit Apollo 11 betrat Neil Armstrong als
erster Mensch den Mond gefolgt von
Aldrin in den Jahren darauf haben es
dann noch zehn weitere US-amerikanische
Astronauten auf den Mond geschafft dabei
konnten sie etliche wissenschaftliche
Untersuchung durchführen und z.B
Gesteinsproben mit zur Erde bringen die
letzte Mission war dann Apollo 17 im
Jahr 1972 danach wurde das Programm aus
Kostengründen eingestellt denn das
Hauptziel die Sowjetunion zu überholen
war ja erreicht seitdem hat kein Mensch
mehr den Mond betreten aber die
verschwörungsmüthen um die Mondlandung
die haben dann erst so richtig an Fahrt
aufgenommen grund war ein Buch von Bill
casing aus dem Jahr
1976 der Titel we never went to the moon
casing war tatsächlich selbst am
mondlandungsprojekt beteiligt wenn auch
nur am Rande er arbeitete als Leiter der
technischen Dokumentation für eine Firma
die für den Bau der Triebwerke der
mondlandungsrakete verantwortlich war er
war also weder Ingenieur noch
Wissenschaftler bezeichnete sich aber
selbst als NASA Insider das war für
viele Leute offenbar glaubwürdig genug
noch heute berufen sich so einige auf se
se eine Behauptung bei einer seiner
bekanntesten Thesen geht's um die
usfahne die Neil Armstrong und Bass
aldren auf dem Mond aufgestellt haben
denn auf den Bildern sieht es so aus als
würde sie im Wind flattern wenn dem
wirklich so wäre wäre das doch auf jeden
Fall ein klares Indiz gegen die
Mondlandung der Mond hat nämlich keine
Atmosphäre wie wir das hier unten auf
der Erde haben und deshalb kann dort
doch kein Wind wehen also wieso weht die
Fahne denn da so schön das kann man sehr
gut in dem videoexeriment hier sehen
hier wird ein Vakuum kreiert damit die
gleichen wie auf dem Mond herrschen dann
wird die Flagge in Bewegung gebracht und
wie man sieht auch im luftleeren Raum
bewegt sie sich warum das so ist erklärt
das sogenannte Trägheitsgesetz das
besagt ganz einfach Dinge die still sind
bleiben auch still Dinge die sich
bewegen bewegen sich weiter zumindest
solange sie nicht von außen beeinflusst
werden da es im Vakuum kein
Luftwiderstand gibt bewegt sich ein
Gegenstand also einfach von alleine
weiter sowie die US-Flagge auf dem Mond
nachdem die Astronauten sie in
Schwingung gebracht haben an dem Mythos
ist ist also nichts dran eine andere
These von Bill casing besagt die
Computer seien damals noch gar nicht in
der Lage gewesen wichtige Berechnung
durchzuführen z.B für die Landemanöver
oder die rückflugbahn und man muss sagen
die USA hatten bis zu dem Projekt so gut
wie keine raumfahrterfahrung innerhalb
von nur einem Jahrzehnt zum Mond
zugelangen war also ein krasses Ziel
eine riesige Herausforderung für die
Beteiligten Fachleute bis heute gilt die
Apollo Computertechnologie als eine der
größten Errungenschaften des Projekts
für die Mission wurden nämlich von
massachusets Institute of Technology
zwei Boardcomputer entwickelt einer für
die Landung und einer für die Flugroute
sie war in ihrer Zeit weit voraus und
nur so groß wie eine Aktentasche zu der
Zeit erinnerten Computer eher an
Kühlschränke ihr Speicher war beim
Vergleich zu heute noch super klein mit
etwas über 70 KB war die Rechenleistung
der Computer so groß wie heute bei einer
Mikrowelle für den Flug zum Mond reichte
das allerdings aus übrigens der
Programmiercode war damals ausgedruckt
schon mehrere tausend Seiten lang im
Vergleich zu heutigen Codes ist es
allerdings nichts die Software wurde
übrigens zu großen Teilen von einer
jungen Frau entwickelt nämlich Margaret
Hamilton sie war zum Zeitpunkt der
Mondlandung erst 33 Jahre alt und gilt
als die erste softwareingenieurin
überhaupt ein Großteil des Erfolgs geht
also auf sie zurück das heißt natürlich
auch eigentlich sind wir heute immer
noch in der Lage auf den Mond zu fliegen
aber warum waren wir dann so lange nicht
mehr da das liegt zum einen daran dass
der Kampf der Supermächte spätestens
seit dem Fall der Mauer vorbei ist der
Anreiz auf den Mond zu fliegen war
danach nicht mehr so groß niemand wollte
noch so viel Geld in die Hand nehmen wie
noch in den 60ern und zum anderen konnte
das Apollo Programm schon sehr viele
Erkenntnisse über den Mond liefern
damals installierte Geräte werden
teilweise heute noch in der Forschung
benutzt indem Laser von der Erde auf
einen Reflektor auf dem Mond geschossen
werden wird z.B die Struktur des Mondes
erforscht allein die Existenz der Geräte
ist quasi schon ein Gegenbeweis für alle
mondlandungszweifler denn wie sollen wir
heute Geräte nutzen die ja in der
Theorie nie aufgestellt wurden
mittlerweile gibt's aber doch wieder
neue Anreize für eine Mondmission und
zwar soll auf Dauer eine sogenannte
Mondstation errichtet werden eine
bemannte Raumstation wie die ISS anstatt
ihre Bahnen um die Erde zu ziehen wird
sie dann um den Mond Kreisen von dort
soll die Mondoberfläche weiter
untersucht werden es sollen also sogar
wieder Menschen den Mond betreten
außerdem soll die Mondstation dabei
helfen den nächsten großen Schritt in
der Raumfahrt zu erreichen nämlich die
Erkundung des Mars Technologien für eine
Reise zum Mars sollen auf der
Mondstation getestet werden aber auf dem
erneuten Weg zum Mond gibt's noch ein
paar Hürden es ist immer noch unsicher
ob die aktuelle Mondmission Artemis 3 im
Jahr 2025 stattfinden kann denn momentan
wird unter anderem noch am Landesystem
gearbeitet der technische Fortschritt im
Vergleich zu früher ist nämlich nicht
nur ein Vorteil denn heute werden viel
mehr Variablen berücksichtigt der
Rechenaufwand der Computer ist also viel
größer das macht die Systeme zwar
sicherer aber der Aufwand ist eben auch
höher die behaup t dass die Technik in
den 60er Jahren noch nicht weit genug
war ist also falsch sie war allerdings
einfacher als heute und damit auch
wesentlich risikoreicher für die
Astronauten übrigens hätten die Sowjets
ein Fake easy aufdecken können man
konnte nämlich damals schon Funksprüche
Orden das haben die Sowjets auch getan
und selbst bestätigt die Funksprüche
zwischen Armstrong Aldrin und Co die
haben wir auf dem Mond geortet so der
nächste Mythos der schwarze Himmel ohne
einen einzigen Stern und ja wenn man
sich aktuelle Bilder der ISS anschaut
ist das erstmal ein nachvollziehbarer
Punkt denn auch im All sieht man
natürlich Sterne nur auf den Aufnahmen
der Mondlandung nicht aber warum auch
das kann man mit einem einfachen
Experiment herausfinden wenn man eine
Person im Dunkeln fotografiert kann man
im Hintergrund kaum etwas erkennen und
wegen des gleichen Effekt sieht man auf
den Bildern des Mondes auch keine Sterne
die Mission wurde nämlich tagsüber
durchgeführt auf dem Mond war es durch
die Sonne so hell dass das Licht der
Sterne im Vergleich sehr schwach war der
Kontrast war also zu groß um das Licht
der Sterne mit der Kamera einzufangen um
sowohl den Mond und die Astronauten als
auch die Sterne abbilden zu können hätte
die Belichtungszeit deutlich länger sein
müssen dadurch werden die Aufnahmen aber
generell auch unschärfer geworden denn
bei höheren Belichtungszeiten werden
Bewegungsabläufe unschärfer und man
wollte ja vor allem die Astronauten und
das Geschehen auf dem Mond sehen und
nicht unbedingt den schönen
Sternenhimmel die Sterne am Himmel
fehlen also nicht weil die Mission ein
Fake war sondern sie sind wegen der
Belichtung der Kamera nicht zu sehen es
gibt aber noch eine andere Sache die
manche Menschen an der Mondlandung
zweifeln lässt schaut mal hier auf dem
Foto Stellen Armstrong und Aldrin die
usflagge auf aber warum ist der eine
Schatten der Astronauten deutlich länger
als der andere und wieso neigen sich die
Schatten zueinander müssen Sie nicht
eigentlich parallel laufen und gleich
lang sein auch von spätere Mission
gibt's Bilder die von Leuten oft als
Beweis für den Fake gesehen werden wie
das hier von Apollo x auch hier sind die
Schatten zueinander geneigt das lässt
sich aber mit den Grundlagen der
Perspektive erklären ein gutes Beispiel
sind hier Eisenbach anschieden obwohl
sie parallel laufen sieht es auf Bildern
so aus als würden sie sich am Horizont
treffen das liegt einfach an der
Übertragung von 3D zu 2D man spricht ja
auch vom Fluchtpunkt und auch für die
unterschiedlichen Längen der Schatten
gibt es eine Erklärung und zwar die
Mondoberfläche die ähnlich wie die der
Erde uneben ist wenn ein Schatten auf
eine flache oder abschüssige Ebene fällt
ist er optisch länger beim Anstieg also
z.B beim Hügel wirk der verkürzt also
einer der beiden Astronauten steht hier
abschüssiger als der andere wodurch der
Schatten länger aussieht also auch für
die falschen Schatten gibt es gute
Gründe im Prinzip lassen sich alle
Thesen die zu Verschwörung rund um die
Mondlandung existieren relativ leicht
aushebeln denn im Gegensatz zu anderen
verschwörungserzählungen wie z.B der
Erzählung vom großen Austausch basieren
sie nicht auf komplexen Konstrukten oder
pseudowissenschaftlichen Annahmen
sondern größtenteils auf Bildern und
deren Interpretationen die Erzählung vom
großen Austausch haben wir übrigens auch
im ZF heute backgroundcheck besprochen
falls euch das interessiert klickt doch
mal hier was mich aber wirklich
fasziniert trotz der vielen Gegenbeweise
hält sich die Mutter aller
verschwörungserzählung nach so vielen
Jahrzehnten immer noch
hartnäckig wie kann das sein woran liegt
das erstmal muss man sagen die
Verschwörung um die Mondlandung hatte es
in den 70er Jahren sehr leicht es war
damals einfach für viele Menschen
unvorstellbar dass wir technisch in der
Lage sind auf den Mond zu fliegen die
angebliche Inszenierung war hier die
leichtere Erklärung außerdem kam die
verschwörungserzählung in einer Zeit auf
in der die LE in den USA generell sehr
verunsichert waren 1971 waren z.B die
Pentagon papers an die Öffentlichkeit
geraten aus denen ging hervor dass die
Regierung unter Lindon B Johnson im
Bezug auf den Vietnamkrieg gelogen hatte
und auch um die Ermordung von Präsident
John F Kennedy gab es viele
Unsicherheiten die US-Bevölkerung war
ganz einfach in einer Vertrauenskrise
auf dieser Basis hatte die
verschwörungserzählung um die
Mondmission viel Spielraum um sich zu
entwickeln und zu verbreiten und das hat
dazu beigetragen dass sie bis heute so
in der Gesellschaft verankert ist
mittlerweile wurde sie in etlichen Dokus
Filmen und Serien Youtube Videos oder
Internetforen besprochen und die
Tatsache dass noch immer viele der
Amerikanerinnen Amerikaner an den Fake
Glauben zeigt auch sie ist schon fast
mehr als eine verschwörungserzählung für
viele Menschen ist der Fake einfach ein
Fakt auch der US-amerikanische
Nachrichtensender Fox gibt der
Verschwörung eine ernstgemeinte
Plattform dort wurde noch im August 2023
der verschwörungserzähler Bart sibrel
interviewt der ein sehr bekannter
Anhänger des mondlandungsfakes ist auch
das Internet und Social Media tragen
heute einen großen Teil dazu bei dass
die verschwörungserzählung noch so
bekannt ist die Verbreitung von
Informationen egal ob wahr oder falsch
geht heutzutage einfach viel schneller
und dafür eignen sich Bilder besonders
gut die Tatsache dass die Verschwörung
um die Mondlandung also vor allem auf
Bildern beruht scheint es der
Verbreitung heute sogar besonders leicht
zu machen denn Bilder haben einen
unglaublichen Einfluss das wird auch in
medialen Debatten immer wieder deutlich
die Black lives merter Bewegung wäre
vermutlich ohne die Macht der Bilder nie
so groß geworden hätte es keine
Aufnahmen der Ermordung von George Floyd
gegeben hätten sich möglicherweise nie
so viele Menschen aktiv solidarisch
gezeigt das liegt daran dass Bilder
stark an Emotionen geknüpft sind sie
triggern bei uns Empfindungen wie
Mitgefühl oder Faszination und dadurch
prägen Sie sich bei uns ein Bilder
werden in der Regel als Abbildung der
Wahrheit angenommen für viele gilt sehen
ist gleich glauben es kann aber auch
nach hinten losgehen denn dafür müssen
Sie nicht unbedingt echt sein erinnert
ihr euch noch daran diese Bilderreihe
von Trumps vermeintlicher Verhaftung ist
im März 2023 viral gegangen der Blogger
Elliot Higgins hatte die KI generierten
Bilder damals erstellt und verbreitet
wenn man genau hinguckt sieht man einige
Bildfehler z.B ist hier ein Bein zu viel
was eigentlich als Satire gedacht war
wurde von vielen aber ernst genommen
viele Menschen waren überzeugt dass der
Ex-Präsident tatsächlich verhaftet wurde
Trump selbst hatte seine anstehende
Verhaftung nämlich kurz vorher
vorausgesagt um seine Supporter zum
Protest aufzurufen das dramatische Bild
seiner veremindlichen Festnahme hat
seine Anhängerinnen und Anhänger also
eher bestätigt dass Bilder also eher als
wahr angenommen werden kann auch
gefährlich sein denn damit können
falsche Informationen verbreitet und die
öffentliche Meinung manipuliert werden
wie eben auch im Fall der Mondlandung
nur dass hier eben die Bilder als Beweis
für eine vermeintliche Fälschung
verbreitet werden wie sieht's denn bei
euch aus kennt ihr Leute die nicht an
die Mondlandung glauben oder habt
vielleicht schon selbst gefragt ob das
wirklich so stattgefunden hat und gibt's
vielleicht noch andere
verschwörungserziählungen die euch
interessieren schreibt es in die
Kommentare und Fall ihr Lust auf mehr
habt findet ihr hier jede Menge andere
verschwörungserzählung im ZF heute
background
Check